près de douze millions de personnes
seraient touchées par la crise du
logement en france un chiffre rappelé
lors de cette réunion par les membres de
la france insoumise de jean luc
mélenchon aux mureaux comme ailleurs les
causes de la crise sont bien connus le
problème dans le pays c'est que le
logement il a trop été considéré dans
les dernières décennies comme une
marchandise comme une autre comme un
bien sur lequel on pouvait spéculer et
puis faire de l'argent fondatrice de
jeudi noir un collectif dédié au mal
logement
leila chaibi et remettent en cause
l'action de l'actuel gouvernement qui ne
serait pas allé au bout de ses promesses
avec la loi allure le problème c'est
qu'elle a été détricoté cette loi elle a
été soumise à la pression des lobbys
mobilier qu'on plus été goûtés que les
lobbies de mal logés la plus grande
inquiétude concerne les 150000 personnes
privées de tout logement sur paris ben
on voit plein de gens dans la rue
ces cinq dernières années on en a vu de
plus en plus qu'on est quand même la
salle une cinquième ou sixième puissance
mondiale
on pourrait faire un effort de
solidarité un effort de solidarité qui
doit aussi se faire sur le plan
écologique pour la france insoumise la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
passe par un habitat économe en énergie
d'efforts importance et de rénover du
point de vue isolation des bâtiments
ça ça me paraît être un poids important
pour ce collectif le logement reste la
première pierre de l'insertion sociale
un chez-soi donne en effet accès à
l'école pour ses enfants et un travail
près de 650 mille personnes seraient
encore hébergées par des tiers faute de
logement personnel